what I'm trying to focus people on is
not so much okay what is your schedule
because that's really just up to you is
what are you doing when you are trying
to learn and that's where I think the
ultra learning approach differs from a
lot of more traditional approaches both
to formal schooling and to self
education is that a lot of people just
the way they're approaching it
so my critique is not you know yeah if
you only have 10 minutes to work on
Spanish and 810 minutes is enough
it's just what are you doing with those
10 minutes and similarly with
programming or with learning Excel or
with you know enhancing a career skill
or what-have-you it's all about what are
you doing with that time so that's what
we'll talk about in the book if you get
it you read through it you're worried
you know what I don't have a lot of time
to spend learning
you'd be surprised not only how much you
can do with the time you have but also
how much learning you're already doing
that you could make more efficient if
you rethink how you're approaching it
because we're all trying to learn new
things in our jobs and lines
I am joined by none other than Scott
hates young Scott welcome to the show oh
it's great to be here great to be
talking you I'm really excited to go
through what we are discussing today
which is Ultra learnings for the
listeners at home who don't know who you
are would you be able to give us a
little bit of a background to you please
sure so I've been writing about learning
in psychology and self-improvement from
for my website for over a decade now and
for a big chunk of that I spent my time
focusing on learning and how do you
learn things particularly outside of
school including the kinds of skills
schools don't teach and part of this
book was just me sort of documenting a
little bit of my journey and all that
really interesting people I've met who
have taken on really interesting
challenging self education projects and
in the process really discovering how
applicable this is to people who you
know they don't want to do something
really crazy they just want to get a
better job or they want to learn a
language for their next trip or they
just want to be good at something but
it's gonna make them feel confident and
enjoy their lives
you did something speaking of crazy
things you did something pretty crazy a
few years ago to me well which which
thing are you talking about the MIT
we'll start with the MIT okay sure so
this was this is more than a few years
ago now actually I was thinking back
yeah eight years ago I believe I did the
MIT challenge so this was a project that
I did after I graduated from University
and so I'll give a little bit of a
backstory just so the just to make it so
you can understand why I would try to do
something like this but I I went to
university and I'd studied business and
I kind of gone into that thinking well I
want to own my own business I want to be
an entrepreneur therefore I should study
business and I only learned after number
of years in school that what Business
School mostly is about is how do you be
a good middle manager in a large company
it's not really telling you how to start
a business it's like here's how you can
be VP of whatever in blah blah blah cork
and so I graduated with this idea that
Oh
I shouldn't have picked this I should
have made you something else now I did
enjoy my time at university but it was
something of a I don't really want to go
back and do more studying and do more of
that experience and so the big thing
that I've been considering is an
alternative when I was going into school
was computer science because here
science we learn how to program you
learn how to make things like the whole
world is run on technology now so even
if you're not a coder you still kind of
need to understand computer science a
little bit to sort of succeed it
particularly as an entrepreneur online
which is where I was wanting ahead with
my career and so I was thinking well
should I go back to school should I go
back for another four years and that
didn't seem very appealing and around
that time I stumbled upon some classes
put on by MIT so they have a bunch of
their classes where they record the
whole lectures they put all the
materials throw it up online anyone can
access it you can access it right now
it's MIT so I think it's
ocw.mit.edu/donate
Oakland course where you'll find you
know hundreds of classes and so when I
found one of these classes I took it and
I was like you know what this is better
than most of the classes I took in
school like them ones that I paid money
for so I took one of these classes now
this is great and I was did a little
tank around I was like you know what
maybe you couldn't just take a class
maybe you could take all the classes
that you would need for degrees so this
is sort of piqued my curiosity because I
was looking around I didn't seem like
anyone had tried to do this before I
don't know maybe there's someone who did
it and it is escaped my attention but I
couldn't I couldn't find anyone who'd
try to do this before I thought why has
no one tried to do this before and so I
dug through and I spend about six months
researching and putting it together and
obviously doing it this way where you're
just doing it online self-study with
course is a bit different than being an
actual MIT student but with a few like I
would say not too big alterations you
can learn pretty much close to the whole
curriculum that an MIT student would do
so this kind of got me excited and as I
was going through it I realized that
once you get outside of the school once
you sort of you stop having due dates
for assignments you have to go to this
lecture hall for your exam you have to
show up to this on time I could watch
videos and you could watch
faster speed through the parts where
they're rambling you know slow down
rewatch parts that are confusing to you
that you could actually do it even
faster than when I was in university so
this sort of led to this idea okay well
what if I tried something a little bit
more ambitious a little bit more
challenging for myself and so I set this
goal this MIT challenge to do this
project over one year rather than the
sort of typical for I mean I didn't take
the summer off but still like over
twelve months and so that was sort of
the first little project I did and that
kind of led me to doing some other
projects and led me to meeting a lot of
people who have done cool projects and
that sort of how we how I got to this
this book ultra learning because I think
it has a lot of implications for other
people I don't think that you can class
doing a Fourier MIT computer programming
course in one year as a little project
[Laughter]
well I mean there are people who I
covered in the book that have
accomplished projects much larger than
that one of the people that I thought
his story was fascinating was eric
barone who he basically about the same
time I started the MIT challenge worked
for five years straight building his own
video game and I've done that a little
bit I did I played around that a little
bit when I was high school into video
games stuff I think the average person
does not really appreciate how
multi-talented you need to be to create
your own video game you need to be good
at music so most people can maybe play
the piano nevermind compose original
music and multiple instruments you need
to be able to do art you need to be able
to program you need became design you
need to be able to do there's like even
within those things there's multiple sub
specialties that typically require a
team of people so he worked on this for
five years had to completely learn tons
of skills from scratch the game he
released stardew valley ended up
becoming a massive hit and made him a
millionaire pretty much overnight so I
think in comparison to some of these
people I feel like my projects are
little but yeah I know it's a little bit
of a relative comparison yeah you're
totally right it's big fish little pond
little fish big pond as soon as you
start to delve into it out of this world
of ultra learners I guess so going back
going back to the MIT project how many
hours were you spending learning per
week so definitely when I started there
was a well obviously I'd picked a fairly
ambitious time for myself lying
just I wouldn't be able to meet it and I
wanted to really go a little bit faster
than what was strictly necessary so
there are 33 classes that would have
been made up the degree with some minor
substitutions but roughly the same
amount of credit hours and I did 32 of
those in that one year I did one one of
the classes before a sort of a test and
so I started off with like a basically
the pace of about a class a week as I
was going through it because that's
enough time to do but if you do that if
you do the math in your head 32 classes
52 weeks in a year 32 classes so that's
actually a little too fast so I did that
for the first think maybe the first nine
or ten I did it in roughly a week one or
two of them I did a little bit longer
and then it was like okay this is
working let's slow it down a little bit
so one of the problems with doing one
class in a row which I would not
recommend to the average person this was
just sort of an artifact of how I did my
project is that it kind of makes it
cramming it's easier to forget things if
you learn it over a short period of time
so I switch to doing it so that I would
be doing like three to five classes in
parallel over like a couple months and
so that was how I did the rest of the
classes is sort of over that a little
bit more delayed pace so in the
beginning it was it was actually a
pretty intense schedule probably about
50 to 60 hours a week but then later on
it was probably a little under full-time
maybe 35 to 40 so not a trivial amount
mind you I want to I don't want to be
like saying that all that's easy I could
do that but if you think about how much
time you spend when you go to university
not to mention that you're giving up
four years of your salary not to mention
that you're probably paying tuition that
you are you know taking out student
loans etc etc I think that the the way I
did that project was a lot less onerous
than getting an actual degree so it
sounds kind of you know I think it
sounds a little weird but I think when
you consider the status quo I think
that's the thing that maybe we should be
questioning a little more yeah there's a
reframing going on here isn't the it
definitely info as I read through ultra
learning it it it just strikes such a
question about the current education
system and I think we can probably can
probably get onto that a little bit
later and we can riff we can riff on the
fact that education maybe doesn't
necessarily work for everyone also I
know that some of the listeners and some
of the guys behind the modern ways
project and the team will be thinking
that your experience with your degree
sounds very familiar and it is the Batum
what I would have said about mine went
to Newcastle University did a business
management degree because I thought that
if I did a business management degree I
would learn how to run a business
because if I really business I'll be
rich and I'll make part of income and I
do this than any other and I I started
my business while I was at uni some I
sat down next to my business partner my
future then to be business partner at my
first ever seminar and now 13 years
later were still together haven't got
rid of each other yet and what I was
seeing was this contrast between what I
was experiencing in the real world of
business and what I was learning and I
was immediately maybe some people more
typically would find the lack of
directness from learning to application
when they eventually get into the job
market for me for me I was becoming
disenchanted with education as I was
going through it which was especially
yeah brutal realisation and then I went
on to do a master's in international
marketing not because I wanted to but
because I thought this is so
transactional and easy that I for the
sake of one more year of commitment yeah
I might as well crack it out and then
once that was done I was at the end of
academics and I think a lot of people a
lot of the listeners may think the same
that you've done this you know with my
urine industry and my master's degree I
was in full-time education for over 17
years full-time education like that was
in from at the age of 5 until the age of
23 like there we go that's that's your
job so the fact and then where is now my
I'm 31 years old and my passion is to
learn new [ __ ] all the time
but somehow the education system and
managed to beat that out of me so I can
see I can see your desire to do it and
another stuff so before we get into the
former and some of the awesome stories
in ultra learning could you run us
through some of the other projects that
you did like your portrait your portrait
drawing and stuff like that oh sure yeah
yeah so so I've done a couple other
objects like public projects I think I
like you I'm always learning things it's
just I don't always try to do them up so
that I'm trying to document everything
and post it online so perfect for people
to see that my key challenge was the
first big one that I did like that I
need another one a little bit after that
and this kind of goes to how I got into
doing this so when I was in university I
spent a year studying abroad in France
so it was an exchange opportunity and
like a lot of people who go to another
country and are gonna be there for a
long time you get this idea of like oh I
can learn another language and I can
come back and I'll be fluent in French
and you know I'll be so impressive and
everything speak to a Florin exchange
girls and all and so I had this idea in
my head and I went to France
and a funny thing happened all the
people around me just spoke English all
the time so all my friends spoke English
including the French ones frustrating it
was it was it was getting really
frustrating because I had been expecting
oh I'm gonna be learning French really
well and I'm you know studying at home
and like I've also got my other business
classes and stuff to do and I'm just
there like what gives you know like I
try to speak to people in French and
they're like I okay up but like you
don't speak very well I'm gonna speak to
you in English and and it was
frustrating and and so it was around
this time that I met a very interesting
guy who I talk about in the book Benny
Lewis and Benny Lewis well I should just
preface this was saying that like like
most people who are in this situation
where you go and you think you're doing
something is that I thought to myself
well maybe I just don't have enough time
like maybe actually learning another
language you know what made me think I
could do it in a year maybe it would
take like 5-10 years and and I just
didn't have enough time and I met this
guy Benny Lewis who does it in three
months now I mean I'm not saying he's
fluent after three months that's sort of
his kind of goal but it's more an
aspiration than saying he ducked
achieved it every time but the thing
that struck me was just how radically
different his approach was because for
me I'm going there and being like oh I
hope that they accept me speaking French
he's just like diving right into
conversations he's speaking from the
very first day he's getting tons of
practice in and achieving quite a bit in
a three-month period of time so seeing
that contrast was one of the main
motivators for me to do the MIT
challenge was just this kind of it was a
little bit of that
what what is it the matrix you know
taking whatever the pill moment is aware
you're like oh this is yeah this is like
different from oh maybe I don't have to
do this the way that everyone else is
doing it and and I of course I applied
it to computer science there but
obviously that example stuck in my mind
I was thinking about you know language
learning and about oh man if I had just
done it that way from the start maybe
things would have been different and so
around that time I had a roommate and he
was planning on going to a masters and
you want to do some traveling so we
started getting to talking and I was
telling him about this and I was like
you know what what if we went to try to
learn languages and he was a little
skeptical he's like wow I don't know
about that like that sounds kind of hard
this kind of thing but I think I
persuaded him and we ended up doing this
project that I called the year without
English where it was basically we would
go to four different countries Spain
Brazil China and South Korea with the
idea that we wouldn't speak English in
those countries I mean we weren't
perfect in every country particular in
Asia but that was the motivation that
you land day one we speak only in that
language to each other everyone we meet
we speak in that language we're not like
oh I don't know whether I'm ready yet to
speak Spanish it was day one going with
that Lenoir funny thing yeah and the
funny thing was is that although when I
described this to other people because
I've seen the reaction when I described
this project other people's like oh my
god I never do that the funny thing was
it was way easier than my time in France
so the kind of irony is is that the
staying at home being in that bubble of
English figures not being an immersion
and really trying to learn French was
harder than just you know ripping the
band-aid off going straight to immersion
from day one doing that process so we
did that project which you know even my
friend who was really skeptical in the
beginning he can speak those languages
too and he we went through and did those
four countries and I've done some other
projects since like you mentioned the
drawing the portraits and I did every
one recently learning quantum mechanics
and I've done some others for cognitive
science and things like that but it's
always for me just trying to what's the
assumption that everyone has about how
you have to do things that if you break
you're able to get better results and
and that's sort of what I wanted to try
to cover in this in this book he's give
people that kind of mindset well I mean
you've definitely got some non-typical
results there I think
learning four languages in the space of
a year what fluency did you get to with
with them so I will say this defining
fluency is really fraught because I find
it for people especially people who are
you know not fluent in a lot of
languages that there's kind of two
assumptions that have to do with what
the one assumption is this is comes from
a story where I told someone this story
and they said like so do you think you
could ask for like you could probably
ask for directions in like a taxi and I
was like well that's actually really
easy like I I could yeah you I could
give you that in half an hour and almost
any language like there's very little to
that that's not really a difficult task
on the other hand there's people who
think you're a hundred percent fluent
like you're completely bilingual and
this kind of theus lee that's not the
case either the way I would like to
qualify it is what we were able to do
rather than some particular language
exam so in the the spanish and
portuguese we were able to make friends
we had an active social life we were
living in the language we could go to
like you know restaurants do whatever we
needed to do in the countries it
probably would have been like spanish
would have been maybe on the cusp of
being able to study in it but maybe a
little bit more work would have been
required to get to that level of
technical understanding for the asian
languages they're obviously just harder
there's more new vocabulary to learn
they're more different so you have to
spend more time learning them but in
chinese i feel like we got fairly well
for those of you who are have some
background in this the level I reached I
wrote the what's called the HSK for exam
so China puts on Ford if I sort they put
on language exams that are divided into
six categories and so at the time I
wrote and passed the level for which is
considered to be kind of a an
intermediate level exam but you can give
you a sense of four out of six it's a
little bit hard to explain if you don't
know what the six levels mean but it can
give you kind of a broad qualitative
sense Korean we were a little bit weaker
on mostly just because doing four
languages in a row getting a little
burnt out but I feel like even there we
were able to get to a level where again
like going to restaurants and talking to
people and making friends and having
conversations is just it's a little bit
more limited you got
the dictionary a little bit more often
yeah I think for most people when they
think about languages competence to just
go day-to-day is what most people would
aim for I don't think many people want
to be able to write war and peace in
that Korean right they're just they're
just I just want to want to be able to
say what's what's the best dish here
what's your phone number
like what was good to go for evening
drinks of blah blah blah I just want to
get around right that's probably the
normal lay person's desire for it but
what's ridiculous is I did two years of
a half GCSE at Spanish and and fair
didn't [ __ ] got a D which is so lame its
school and now outside of May llamo
Chris it's like what like that and and
so yeah some stuff I've picked up whilst
partying in Ibiza like yeah yeah like
I've almost completely forgotten it so
to hear that you were able to achieve
impotency in four languages in a year
will be a big surprise to a lot of
people well so that's the thing I feel
like when I before I did this so again
my experience from France that I thought
like even learning a language
conversationally in a year I thought was
very fast like I thought well you know
what maybe it just can't be done and
after like doing the research for this
book I find that like kind of the the
critique some insiders have is not that
you know not that it can't be done but
to the level of fluency that I'm
thinking right now is just kind of like
oh yeah of course you could do so
there's a lot like it's actually lots of
people do it so it's not even really oh
you need to be some kind of genius to do
this it's just do you have the right
approach and that's really what I try to
talk about in the book you know
particularly directness this is one of
the things we talk about because I think
the way they teach languages in school I
don't really want to fault language
educators because often they're trying
to get the students to do the right
thing the problem is just the
assumptions of how classrooms work make
it very hard to break out of it if a
teachers is okay with you need to
practice this at home and then they
don't do that I can't really fault the
teacher but at the same time I can kind
of fault the paradigm of going to a
class and the way students think is I
should do a little bit of homework on
piece of paper and that should be enough
whereas the immersive approach
which by the way you don't need to be in
the country to do that if you want to do
that there are services like like I
talked EECOM and live mocha or even jump
on and have conversations with people
around the world if you get language
partners it's free and so this is
something you can totally do you can
even you know have a if you have a
spouse or someone who's interested in
learning the language too you could have
a little okay at home we just speak in
this language and practice with each
other so is I don't want to make this
idea that like well you have to go on
some special full-time immersion project
to do this it's just about thinking
critically about how you want to acquire
those skills and I mean languages
there's just one example yeah so one of
the things that might be going through a
number of people's heads at the moment
before we get into the specific
strategies of all yawning itself one of
the things would be well I can't
dedicate 50 60 hours a week to doing
computer programming I can like just
drop my life and like blast blast off to
Spain with my with my mate for a bit so
their concern might be the amount of
time dedication to that but I'm pretty
certain having read the book that the
time that you put towards something
doesn't actually need to be that that
ruthless you can still get lives in some
pretty strong effects with a lower time
investment so what you're saying is
exactly right so I kind of define the
ultra learning approach in my book as
aggressive self-directed learning and I
think a mistake and it's it's a common
one because when you want to talk about
dramatic stories those are probably
going to be someone who did something in
short period of time right like that's
just sort of what makes for a more
interesting story and that necessarily
is going to lean towards people who are
doing it full-time so that that is a lot
of the stories that I have in the book
not all of them but a lot of them and I
think one mistake to draw from that is
oh me being able to learn Spanish
full-time is critical or me being able
to you know I'd like to learn computer
programming but I can't really put in
more than two hours a week on it and you
know so this doesn't apply to me but
what I'm trying to focus people on is
not so much okay what is your schedule
because that's really just up to you is
what are you doing when you were trying
to learn and that's where I think the
ultra learning of
approach differs from a lot of more
traditional approaches both to formal
schooling and to self education is that
a lot of people just the way they're
approaching it
so my critique is not you know yeah if
you only have ten minutes to work on
Spanish and eight ten minutes is enough
it's just what are you doing with those
ten minutes and similarly with
programming or with learning Excel or
with you know enhancing a career skill
or what-have-you it's all about what are
you doing with that time so that's what
we'll talk about in the book if you get
it you read through it you're worried
you know what I don't have a lot of time
to spend learning you'd be surprised not
only how much you can do with the time
you have but also how much learning
you're already doing that you could make
more efficient if you rethink how you're
approaching it because we're all trying
to learn new things in our jobs and
lines yeah we are so we've danced around
it for long enough we're more aggressive
self-directed learning which is an ultra
leisure project where do we stop so the
first step is to figure out what you
want to learn and I think that that
sounds like a trivial step and for some
people maybe you know you've really
wanted to learn guitar or painting or
French for a long time so you can
already know what you want to learn but
for a lot of people it's not that they
want to learn something particular but
they want to get some outcome in their
life so they want to get in shape or
they want to start a business or they
want to get a promotion or they want to
do they want to do something else and
learning is how you get at it and so the
starting point is to figure out well
what is the skill that you actually want
to learn so there's lots of different
ways you can go about it I have
different techniques in the book for
kind of eliciting ways to figure it out
one of the ways I really like is what I
call the expert interview method so
basically if you want to let's say
improve your career a good idea is to
get some idea of what skill you might
want to learn so okay I'm an engineer
and what what if I improve my public
speaking ability and then you talk to
some people that have the job you know
that you want or that have already
accomplished what you wanted you just
sort of ask them hey what do you think
about if I did this kind of project or
got better at this now I do think it's
okay to learn something and then realize
oh that wasn't exactly what I needed
that sort of part of the learning
process but part of what I talked about
an ultra learning is the process of
thinking about why do you want to learn
what you want to learn is not just an
issue of well then I might learn the
wrong thing but even if you
even if you decide what you want learn
like you want to learn French thinking
about how you're gonna use that French
can be really informative for how you
should actually practice it because I
would have a completely different set of
recommendations for learning languages
if your goal was to learn like ancient
Greek or something to read classics like
its you're not gonna be trying to have
conversations with people an ancient
Greeks Greek at like parties and stuff
you're going to be approaching it in a
different way so thinking about why you
want to learn something and what's the
situation you want to apply it in is so
critical so that's another principle I
talked about in the book directness
which is essentially that hundred years
of educational psychology research shows
us that transferring skills from one
domain to another is really hard to do
and it only usually happens once we're a
near a level of mastery so in a
beginning standpoint it's very difficult
and so the ultra learning approach and
what I talk about the book is always to
try to fine-tune how you're practicing
it so that it more matches the situation
where you want to apply it and this has
a lot of profound impact because if you
choose the wrong way to practice it you
can spend hundreds of hours learning
something and then be like wow this
isn't actually very useful yeah I think
a lot of people will potentially spend
quite a bit of time thinking about what
it is that they want to learn and I know
certainly that I get stuck in that
paralysis by analysis or the the one the
planners dilemma as me and some of the
guys have come up with in the modern
wisdom group that the the terror or the
understanding that compounding interest
is the eighth wonder of the world is a
little bit of a blessing and a curse
because if you you always terrified if I
take the wrong fork in the road think
about all of the missing compounding
interest that I'm going to lose out like
you're not doing anything so choosing
something yeah I know that you'll deal
talked about this but an ultra learning
project based on my understanding of it
the skills that you learn from one will
make all subsequent ones more easy the
fact that there are particular Cadence's
there's the strategies there's simply
the art of like a massive amount of
recall which is probably going to be
like every also learning fraud
and like progressive overload on
strengthening a muscle the second time
the e period is your strength training
you will have greased the groove from
the first one and we'll pick up some
skills more easily so that's one of the
things that I try to talk about in the
book is that you know you could you
could read this book but reading the
book is just the starting point because
even though I've tried my very best to
try to break down the core ideas and
what I've learned from doing this
there's a lot you have to learn from
experience and that's again kind of this
directness idea in the book is that just
reading about something does not
necessarily make you good at it and so
what I'm hoping to give people is sort
of a roadmap but obviously they have to
you know start driving their car along
it and so for for me when I'm giving
people suggestions for ultra learning
projects is don't sweat too much about
which ones you pick for right off the
bat you pick a short one doesn't have to
be crazy ambitious pick something you'd
like to learn because you're gonna start
to find these things like what you said
you're you're talking about Cadence's
and rhythms but lots of things like oh
this is the difficulty with this this is
the thing that you really have to pay
attention to versus oh no actually I was
spending a lot of time with this that's
actually not a problem I don't need to
worry about that not to mention there's
a lot involved with the self motivation
angle so a big skill you'll learn is
just like you said how do you pull the
trigger on projects how do you design
them so that you actually can finish
them you know so many people come to me
and they tell me oh you know what I'd
really like to do this but everything I
start like I start learning guitar
two weeks later I give it up I start
learning French I give it up I started
doing this I give it up and a big part
of this process is okay let's get
through one complete very like even if
it's a small project so you can be like
ah this is start to finish how it works
and then you can just iterate and repeat
so a lot of what you're learning when
you do these projects is not just the
approach to learning guitar or French
but how do I have this lens this eye for
viewing all the things in my life and
how do I accomplish them and finish them
and break down things that I don't know
how to do right now yeah so would you
potentially suggest that people aim
towards one which is slightly less
ambitious than trying to do a four-year
degree in one year yeah that that
project but I mean and that project was
my first kind of public project but I
think
I kind of came to it after taking a lot
of smaller projects as well so I
wouldn't recommend doing something crazy
ambitious unless you have like you look
back at your track record and like well
maybe I haven't done an ultra learning
project but I've you know started my own
company and youngness not even citizens
oh yeah some people have that but if you
don't feel like you have that don't feel
like this concept isn't for you that's I
guess the point I'm saying that you can
break it down to something very small so
one of the things I often recommend is
you know pick a goal that you can that
is really bite-sized it seems kind of
contrary to the idea of ultra learning
but you know I want to learn enough
Spanish for my upcoming trip to Madrid
so that I can you know order tapas at a
restaurant is a perfectly fine you know
month-long project to do on the side you
know after work before your vacation
that's totally fine so don't think they
all have to be these big dramatic
projects but when you start speaking in
Spanish in Madrid maybe you'll think hey
you know maybe I could bigger right
exactly got you so we've chosen a
project the listeners have decided what
it's going to be
they haven't waiting around for too long
they've not obsessed over it they've got
the project where are they going next so
the next thing to do is to look at what
is the actual mechanism you're going to
use to learn it that sounds a little
abstract but I think it's something that
we often don't think about because when
you're in a classroom the teachers like
okay here's the textbook you know sit
and listen to me talk for a while go to
your homework and then you'll pass the
exam and maybe there's a little bit of
thought to like how should I study this
but there isn't that much choice you've
just been told what to do and that's so
ingrained in our thinking that very few
of us like when I talk to them about
learning a language for instance and
they're like well where do you go to
study it like the concept of learning it
on your own with just sort of like
random resources seems kind of
impossible to them and languages are
just one example like programming or you
know any other skill you could think of
a lot of people are like well I need to
go into some kind of formal process and
for some that might be the best way of
doing it but what I usually recommend is
doing a little bit of research ahead of
time so you can figure out okay what are
all the materials that I could use for
this if it's a popular skill there's
likely many so it could be a book you
want to use as a guide it could be a
online course it could be an app it
could be something that you want to use
as a resource if
if popular skill again programming
languages are good examples there might
be many resources so you might want to
jot some of them down the next thing I
like to look at is not thinking in terms
of the material you're using but what is
the actual activity of learning because
a lot of people think the activity of
learning is you know picking up a book
and flipping through it like this but
really what the activity of learning is
is some kind of practice and that's true
even for book learning subjects even if
you're you know learning about I had a
guy who was I was helping with who is
learning military history and we decided
no his practice activity was going to be
to write like some essays or some book
reviews of some of these things because
he was taking these ideas and then he
had to synthesize it and make it into a
format so he could have a conversation
with people about it and so focusing on
that practice activities are really
important piece because a lot of us just
take the material ok I'll flip through
it and I'm you know I'm not very good at
this right so thinking about the
practice material is very important and
then once you get into the project then
there's a lot more tweaks you can make
and then you can start looking at ok
feedback what kind of feedback am I
getting how do I have to turn that
little dial drills like how can I break
apart this more complicated skill to get
good at some of the components certain
skills have like a natural pattern to
them languages for instance it's very
easy to get hung up on not having enough
vocabulary so once you're in the process
of learning it you're actually speaking
with other people you may want to inject
more vocabulary so you can speak better
or or practice grammar if it's if it's
tripping you up so there's lots of
little things you can do once you get
started and and the way I like to see it
about it the way everyone in the book is
that the nine principles of ultra
learning are like these little dials
that you can kind of twist so that
you're kind of like oh this is a little
off and as you do more than you get a
better feel of it-- mmm this is why this
isn't working this dial is turned to how
can I turn it over to where it needs to
be so that would be my advice for people
who are getting started yeah you give a
a proposed ratio of planning to work
unlink in advance of a project and
certainly we've been talking a lot
recently on this podcast about the
difference between strategy and
execution and I know one of the problems
with executing is the fact that by
strategizing you don't ever need to
actually meet the real world with
whatever
that you're trying to do and your dreams
your much sooner going to forego the
potential of failure in place of never
starting at all that's one of the
reasons also actually you have to put
your money where your mouth is get off
your ass and do something so yeah yeah I
think why I particularly liked was the
prescription for not getting bogged down
in the planning period that planning is
important and that revisiting the and
reassessing your learning method is
important but probably less important
than just getting started just do
whatever the project is well the way I
like to see it is that the planning
you're doing is a little bit like
packing for a trip so you want to make
sure that you got enough and your trip
so that you get there and I don't know I
don't have my passport or I don't have
this and then the trips ruined and then
you're not doing anything but at the
same time you could be that person that
you know brings every single thing from
their house in their suitcase and
they're lugging it along and and then
they're not able to actually flexibly
cope with things in the real world like
when you're on a vacation you can buy
things in that country so if you don't
have sunscreen you can probably get it
there or something like that so to
continue that metaphor the way I like to
think about it is that the longer and
more ambitious your project is the more
time you should spend on planning
because for two reasons one is just the
preparation part but the other reason is
just psychologically you need to commit
to it so one of the things that I found
very valuable at the MIT challenge was
doing this research ahead of time and so
I spend about six months part time doing
some research and the reason I found it
very valuable is it started to get me in
the mental headspace of like okay this
is what its gonna be like for a year
this is what I'm gonna have to do is how
I'm gonna have to think about it whereas
if I just said on Monday okay next
Monday I'm doing this I would not have
psychologically prepared enough so that
when it starts and things get difficult
I'm like okay no you know to continue
the travel metaphor I'm going home I
don't like this yeah so there is a
balancing point I suggest what I call
the 10% rule which is that for projects
you spend about 10% of the total time
you expect doing some preparation now
again it really depends on what you're
trying to do if you're trying to do
something smaller like we were talking
about some smaller projects those are
probably best off just getting started
with them and then changing your
approach while you're doing them
I've done that in projects before so I
mentioned doing this portrait drawing
challenge and so I had kind of a
approach that I used for like the first
two weeks and then I'm like alright I
can get about this good but I can't get
any better with this I need to find
something else you know
hit the brakes did some more research
found okay actually there's this
different method that I can use and I
took a little course and learn that
method like oh okay this actually works
a lot better and so you might find that
when you're learning as well that you're
doing things in the air kind of like oh
this doesn't seem to be getting me where
I thought it was gonna go and now I need
to readjust so I talked a lot about this
sort of like balance between what I call
learning and meta learning so the
learning is the actual thing you're
trying to do you're acquiring knowledge
you're getting information about what
you're trying to learn and the meta
learning meta of course refers to when
things are kind of about themselves so
meta learning would be learning about
learning and so for the meta learning is
the kind of understanding how learning
in this subject works so how do you
learn a language how do you learn
programming how do you get good at salsa
dancing or public speaking or Taekwondo
or whatever it is and that kind of meta
approach there's sort of an oscillation
between what you're doing to actually
learn the skill and then what are you
doing to try to understand that same
process you can know inefficiencies and
find things you can improve in it yeah
one of the things that I think a lot of
people may be thinking at home is well
like I've been school for eight years or
I was never a good learner
I was never academic or whatever it
might be obviously there are there are
some people out there whose skill
acquisition naturally is pretty rapid
but also there's there's some
commonalities between them what was the
story was it this Scottish physicist
lady this Scottish sine Mary Somerville
yeah yeah can we hear the story about
her because I love that yeah so Mary
Somerville I cover her in the chapter on
focus and I really loved her biography
because she's not the most famous person
like a lot of people perhaps haven't
heard of her but she's quite an
accomplished woman in terms of science I
think her biggest accomplishment was a
sort of a
translation and expansion of Laplace's
celestial mechanics which was kind of
like the follow-on to newton's principia
mathematica so very advanced lots of
calculus lots of like advanced physics
for you know this was the this was the
cutting edge in the 18th century but the
interesting thing about her story is
that you know she grew up in kind of a
poor household in Scotland and she was a
woman and so in that time period you
know she didn't have a choice about like
you know pursuing science professionally
and so she kind of had to make do with
the fact that you know people would come
over and be like okay I kind of visit
you now drop whatever or you know
there's a story I really like where she
was you know she's raising children and
she's talking to some collie who's like
convinces her to study bought me so she
spends the morning studying botany while
she's breastfeeding her child and
there's these kind of little tidbits of
her life of just showing dedication to
to learning things but at the same time
and I mean it's hard to peer into this
because obviously when someone super
accomplished and then they're being
modest there's a little bit you kind of
doubt how how hottest it is or how much
false modesty there is but you read her
biography and there's so many examples
of her doubting her own capacity and her
like well like I couldn't I didn't think
I would be able to ever learn a language
and then she learns like six or
something like that so such there's a
lot of openness didn't she she said that
she's like super distruction Emery yeah
memory though yeah yeah she had a bad
memory well that I picked her as an
example for this chapter unfocused just
because she she was you know in this
situation where it's not conducive to
focus you know like you you think about
Albert Einstein or you know in the quiet
patent clerk formulating his theory of
relativity whereas this is a woman who
you know she's got four kids he's got
people coming by and she's got to take
care of the house and you know do all of
that kind of stuff and people aren't
taking you seriously or a lot of people
aren't and so you you don't really have
the ability to just okay I'm dedicating
myself to this so I wanted to pick her
as an example for focus just because
it's just sort of it to show that you
know so much of what we think of as
focus is a kind of choice about what to
do rather than simply you know being in
a log cabin somewhere isolated from the
world yeah
I absolutely loved that that story it's
the same as the stuart mcgill podcast
that i did recently where there was a
guy who shattered his sacrum and his l5
that just obliterated two of his
vertebrae and he was a world record
squat holder and he said he's once i get
pain free i want to go back and break my
scott record and it's like the
radiologists have seen his MRI just it
it just looks like a bombs gone off in
his back yeah i like look money you're
gonna be looking to be walking again and
then sure enough three and a bit years
later he goes back breaks his squat
record and I think that framing that
contrast effect similar to his
Somerville's story that you've just
given us there or Brian Carroll the
power lifter that I'm talking about now
you know he it frames people's own
excuses in a really harsh light of day
and I think it's so it's so important
for people like me as well right like I
make yelling all the all the excuses in
the world I interviewed we had Peter C
Brown make it stick we had him on a year
ago and even yeah even hearing look you
can employ these F these by the way if
you're listening and you're a recent
subscriber you may have missed it Peter
Brown is cited on the back of ultra
learning actually I think it's one of
the one of the guys that's helped to
formulate your ideas for this and it's a
fantastic episode I'll link in the show
notes below if you want to go back check
it out well yeah like I was listening to
him say look there's a formula for you
know repeated exposure is not the key
repeated
recall is etc etc aside from all this
stuff and I'm still telling myself this
story about oh yeah but you know I'm
tired I've got there so this that any
other and then there's Mary Somerville
like baking baking baking a cake whilst
breast feeding a child whilst rewriting
like one of the most difficult things in
all of physics whilst being like under
the feet of the kind of I guess typicals
route that women in the 18th 1800
supposed to take and all this sort yeah
so what I'm saying is to the listeners
at home your excuses are probably not as
strong as hers so undertake learning
project well you know what I I would
take it even I would take it perhaps the
softer take but I I know
from talking to a lot of people that
they've had bad experiences in school
and they associate school with learning
so when you tell them this is gonna be a
big book about learning it just brings
up all this drama alright so they have
this like that nightmare of like oh my
god I've got the exam and I'm not
prepared so I'm not doing it and so one
of the things I wanted to talk about
this is sort of an interesting thing
that I've had with the people who've
read sort of some of the earlier copies
is they come back to me and say hey you
know what like I don't see myself as an
ultra learner but when you're talking
about this that and I said I was like
you know what I did that for this thing
that I got you know I I did that when I
was learning photography or or when I
was you know trying to start my business
or when I was you know it could be
something completely on a khadeem ik and
they they're like yeah but I was doing
that and so the thing I want to point
out is that learning is not school
school is I don't think there's anything
wrong with school and I've learned a lot
of subjects that you know you could
study academically and I think that's
great but when we think about learning
school is just a really narrow aspect of
so if you weren't good at that narrow
aspect if you you know weren't top of
your class and you feel bad about it
there's so many other things that you
can learn so many other things that you
are learning all the time things that
you're spending time trying to figure
out trying to get better at trying to
improve that I think understanding the
process of learning is really
understanding the process of this kind
of mental self-improvement so anything
that you want to understand better get
better at is going to be through
learning and so this is really what I
wanted to try to write the book about is
not to you know shame people for not
using the right studying approaches or
not to make you feel bad because you
don't see yourself as an ultra learner
but to point out you know that thing
that you did in the past that went well
this is why it worked and this is how
you can do those kind of things in the
future so that's what I've been trying
to do with this book is and I'm hoping
that when people read it they're gonna
see parallels in their own life and just
know how to apply that more consistently
for the future what other strategies
have we got we've got directness which
is a similarity between the thing you
are learning in the outcome that you
want to achieve or the way that you are
practicing and the outcome that you want
to achieve on the other side we've got
we've talked about drilling which as an
analogy I was explaining to someone the
other day is the equivalent in CrossFit
of look
each of the lifts individually are
working on your pull-up technique and
then your your direct learning would be
doing a Matt con doing a workout what's
on the whiteboard so you drill down
little right the specific elements I
tell you one of the in fact two of the
two of my most favorite models which
you've come out of this we're big fans
of mental models on the podcast and one
of them was the rate-determining step
rate-limiting step by step and the other
one is judgment of learning yes yes okay
so I loved both of those let's talk
about them
how could you happy to jump in so the
the rate-limiting step is actually a
concept from chemical reactions so a lot
of times when you have a chemical
reaction you have like some molecule
here in some molecule there and they
like banging into each other and and
they like separate off and you get a
different molecule and often there's
more than one step so for a lot of
chemical reactions you're putting a big
stuff in a big vat of liquid and and
there's one thing that leads to another
thing that reacts to another thing that
reacts to another thing etc etc and one
of the concepts from chemistry which I
think is really interesting for this
process is that sometimes one of those
steps is a bottleneck so it happens way
slower or with more energy or more
difficulty than than the other steps and
that will be the step that governs the
rate of the reaction so you can speed up
that step everything else gets faster so
I'm kind of creating an analogy this to
learning because sometimes and this
doesn't have to be thinking about things
in terms of happen sequentially but just
you can imagine that there are
components to the thing that you're
doing and one of those will be the thing
that governs your overall performance so
the analogy I used again from language
learning was it very often vocabulary is
the rate limiting step because
vocabulary is that if you could just
improve your vocabulary assuming again
not this is not always the case but if
you're practicing and you're using
directness and you're you're speaking a
lot if you could just triple your
vocabulary you would be much more fluent
than you are right now that's just
obviously true so then you can start to
say okay how do I get that vocabulary
another example could be you know if
you're talking about mathematics for
instance it could be that understanding
having a really good intuition of one of
the core concepts is the thing slow
you're down or it could be something
technical it could be that you're not
doing your algebra correctly you
sometimes make mistakes and that's why
you're slowing it down so rate limiting
step is one of the things that I talk
about when you should be keeping an eye
for for drills is like is there one
thing that like really if you can get
better at this one thing you'll get
better at all the things and then the
other thing I like to look at is what I
call cognitive components so when you
are trying to practice a complete skill
like think about driving your car this
is a good example so when you're driving
a car you're doing a lot of things you
have to have your foot on the
accelerator pedal you have to move it
over to brake occasionally you have to
be steering you have to have your
signals you have to check your mirrors
you have to make sure cars aren't coming
under it make sure pedestrians aren't
running across the road you have to make
sure that you know all the little bells
and whistles in your car or like not you
know saying the engines on fire and this
kind of thing and when you start that
feels completely overwhelming like
there's so much stuff happening and so
what what you can do when you're
learning is you can often like try to
focus on one of these elements at a time
now obviously as a car if you just focus
on the accelerator pedal you're gonna
crash really easily but for a lot of
other skills that's not necessary you
can just focus on doing that so if
you're drawing a picture you could focus
on just putting the lines in the right
place rather than worrying about the
shading at the same time or if you are
working on public speaking you could
just focus on you know how is my pacing
am I going too fast or too slow and the
reason for doing it this way and there's
different ways of splicing apart skills
is it very often the limit to
improvement is that when there's so many
things going on it's hard to get better
at any one aspect because your mental
resources are kind of spread over
everything and so what they sort of
deliberate practice approach or the
approach that I talked about in that
chapter is slicing things down so that
you can focus on these sort of smaller
elements and that there's different ways
for doing that for different skills yeah
moving under the judgment of learning
things so this is right it's actually
not a massive section in the book it's
only a couple of paragraphs but like
[ __ ] me they really sideswiped me
honestly
Scott I'm telling you man like I was
reading it and I was like that's that's
me right there there's an asymmetry
between how you feel learning is going
and how learning is actually going and
it's reflected in the data as well isn't
it at least in the short term
and I was just that so my company we run
club nights right we have about 400
students that work for us 18 to 21 or at
university doing some doing difficult
degrees some of them doing less
difficult degree but all of them
learning right and there's our office
gets used like a private library typical
to a lot of universities any uni
students they're listening join a
promotions company that has the nicest
and most convenient office that you can
become an event manager they'll give you
a key and then you can just go in and
learn in there instead of going into the
library that's I think the life hack
them decided to use yes but yeah I look
at their learning strategies and some of
the guys are using a review method and
some of the guys are using a recall
method would you be able to just take us
through judgment of learning for sure so
I'll speak about is specifically this
judgment of learning findings so this is
research done by Jeffrey karpicke and
Janelle Blount I believe Janelle Blount
was I think it's karpicke is the lead
researcher on that and he has done a lot
of work on the testing effect and what
he calls retrieval and this is a similar
to what you were talking about with the
make it stick that essentially this was
a very interesting study I just thought
this result was fascinating but they
took streets and they broke them up into
different groups and assign them
different studying techniques so this
students didn't choose what studying
technique they were using they were
assigned it and so I believe the four
groups were one of them was they
reviewed the material once so meaning
like reading it over the other one they
reviewed it multiple times and then
there was one that was concept mapping
and then the final one was what's called
free recall where basically have a blank
piece of paper and you try to write down
everything you remember so it's not like
it's not like a test or a prompt it's
just okay what do you remember from that
and interestingly they didn't ask the
student at which one did they think
could do better out of these four but
what they did ask the students is how
well do you think you learned the
information so that was the question to
them so they've given them a technique
and they said how well deal information
and what was interesting is that the
students who did review repeated review
thought that they learned the material
the best and the students who did free
recall thought that they learned the
material the worst and when you actually
test them it does the complete opposite
that those who do the free recall do
above and beyond the best compared to
repeated review and so the reason the
sort of explanation for this proposed by
karpicke and Blunt and other researchers
is what you were calling this judgment
of learning is that we don't actually
have the ability to peer into our mind
and see that there's information stored
there instead we use a certain proxy
signal to try to guess how well we've
learned something and one of these is
considered the fluency of the
information so when you're doing
repeated review you're seeing it a lot
and that processing feels easier and
easier so each time you review it you're
like oh yeah I remember this I remember
this I remember this and that's
convincing you that you understand it
very well now the free-recall people
when you put a blank piece of paper and
you try to recall like I'll give this as
an exercise okay after this podcast is
done or you can just pause it right now
try to recall what we talked about so
far in this podcast you'll be surprised
be like oh wow actually it's really hard
to remember a lot of things to Spain and
then so maybe they can jot down a few
things but the thing is is that's really
hard to do and so when you're doing this
really hard thing you're like oh wow I
actually don't know this at all and so
your judgment of how much you learned is
much lower however the act of trying to
recall it makes your memories much
better so there's a bit of a paradox
here that when you think that you learn
something really well because you can
process it really fluently is actually
when you don't have it memorized and
when you are doing free recall and
you're like oh my god this is so
difficult that's when you're really
learning it and this I think was just
sort of a very small slice but really um
really typical of the whole ultra
learning idea is that something that
feels nice and easy and comfortable is I
feel a lot less effective than the thing
where oh wow this is frustrating and
difficult and hard and and challenging
for me but you're actually gonna learn
much faster so there's this kind of
paradox of learning there it's the same
especially going back to the CrossFit
analogy the the strong guys in the gym
will continue to work on strengths
because it makes them feel good they
have a degree of fluency in that I feel
oh I'm progressing that well yes you are
but you're deficient in this particular
area and if you were to work on that
instead your overall game
improve and the same thing goes for this
I think I'm right in saying that it's
actually matched in someone's ability to
take tests immediately after review I
think in the super super short term
review is more effective like very like
ours or maybe even less than ours so I
don't know I don't know the exact
timeframe that they did this study
there's been different studies on this
but generally when you show someone
something so the basic idea is really
easy to understand if I were to like
imagine that there's no delay imagine
that I like put a word on the screen
let's say the word is dog and then it
just like what was that word well you're
gonna know it for sure right yeah um
however if if I say you know like you
read dog like you know 10 minutes ago
and then I said what was that word maybe
you would have forgotten it by now if I
just asked you to recall it because if
you didn't recall it successfully you
don't know what the word is so there is
a sense in which review can be a little
better in the short term and it's just
that we don't really I guess what I
would put it this way that our
intuitions about how we processed
information don't actually say a lot
about how well we're going to remember
information in the future if you all
have experienced this when you go to a
party and someone tells you their name
and you're like oh yeah I know that name
two seconds later and so it's it's when
this person tells you your name it's
like oh yeah Steve oh that makes sense I
won't forget that and then five seconds
later you forget and the reason why is
because when he said Steve you're like
yeah that's a normal name that people
have yeah and we're processing it
fluently so you're like oh okay I know
that but then when it's two minutes
later and you have to be like oh this
guy what's his name yeah you forget it
and it's not just I'm not here to
criticize people are doing this is human
nature and so I do this the same way I
also forget people's names at parties
the thing is is that you need to
understand this when you're approaching
learning projects when you're learning
things like languages or medicine or
things which require a lot of
memorization or things that have a lot
of memory because if you are not
approaching it right you're gonna put in
a lot of effort that's just gonna go to
waste because it's not actually gonna be
stored for recall later introduce
yourself apart ease as something very
memory
like Xavi eh oh yeah yeah like some some
really exotic name that's never got [ __ ]
me remember it's a VA from last night
but yes I'm moving on moving on to where
we up to now like retrieval I guess
we're kind of in and around there and I
guess a lot of people when they think
about learning they think about
memorization right they think about like
school remembering formulas for
chemistry remembering like algebraic
equations or you know even in our
business degrees like who was it that
came up with the scientific management
method and stuff and you're talking
about any on board but you know
retrieval and especially for me I'm
particularly interested in this
retrieval is learning something or even
comprehending it but they're not being
able to recall it is essentially the
same as not knowing it like if you can't
ever recall it like you erect so so oh
yeah I was just gonna say on this point
about retrieval the perfect sort of
illustration of why the ability to
retrieve things matters and indeed not
to say the ability to memorize things
better matters but the ability to have
knowledge inside your head so I'll put
it that way is that in the last 20-30
years essentially all human knowledge
has been put on the internet that you
can search with the right type into
Google in about five to ten seconds
right but the average person is not
thirty thousand times as smart as they
were in like the 60s and so that itself
should be an illustration that just
merely having the ability to look
something up when you need it is not
enough to be smart
yeah totally that's such an interesting
comment on what most people would
consider as knowledge right there's a
recent I did listen it although I'm
about to say neva rava cameras on Joe
Rogan recently and it is by far one of
my favorite podcasts of 2019 and in that
he talks about people having a
simulacrum of intelligence which is just
recall and he's like nobody needs that
anymore
nobody needs to have just recall he's
like we have the internet for that what
we need is understanding comprehension
the ability to link multiple different
concepts together if you haven't already
I'll link you once we once we finish the
podcast
is an absolute GameChanger but yeah
looking at specific tactics for recall
what were the ones which you yourself
found to be most useful or what works
best with your particular style of ultra
learning so just just before I jump into
that one of the reasons I just want to
bring this up cuz I thought it was
interesting that retrieval is one of the
principles I had and originally when I
was writing this book I kind of thought
well retrieval is just one of the other
ideas so retrieval is just feedback that
you know you just get feedback and
therefore you know if you try to
retrieve things because you're getting
feedback feedback is good or retrieval
is just directness that when you do a
test if you practice doing something
like the test it's similar to the test
and that's why you learn it and the
thing that I found really funny is that
retrieval is actually a separate thing
there is a separate idea there that is
important that is not related to those
ideas directly at least and that was why
I wanted to include it and so the first
thing I want to point out is that a lot
of the research on retrieval seems to be
done with the kind of memorization tasks
that you might loathe but just because
they're easier to study in an
experimental setting so lists of words
or matching questions there has been
retrieval stuff on more complicated
things but again the more complicated it
gets the harder it is to study there
might be more confounding effects so
psychologists tend to prefer simple
memorization things however it's my
belief and I'm stretching a little bit
beyond what the research says exactly is
that retrieval is really a process of
all skills so even though a lot of the
research is about like how do you recall
a foreign language word when you hear it
spoken it's really a process of
everything that you do and what it is
when you think of retrieval it is I'm in
a particular situation where there is
some kind of cue from the environment so
that could be I'm speaking to someone in
another language and I need to
communicate something or it could be you
know I'm writing a program and I need to
solve this particular problem or it
could be you know I'm dancing and I want
to be able to do this kind of turn or
something like this and there's a cue in
the environment and you need to be able
to access the sort of pattern that's
stored in your head for dealing with
that situation appropriately and the
challenge is that often that chap that
pattern will be stored somewhere but
it's not linked to the cue in your mind
so this sort of path between where the
trigger point is and where the
you is is not linked together and so you
have the knowledge but you can't use it
and so I talked about in the book a lot
of different tactics you can use for at
Revo but the easiest one is just to
practice doing things don't have the
book open put the book closed and try to
recall it you know when I was reading
that when I was doing the research for
this book I had a bunch of journal
articles I've got a big binder stack on
top of my bookshelf now journal articles
and once I was sort of discovering this
I was like you know what I should do I
should just start writing down what did
I learn from this journal article on a
blank piece of paper at the end of this
I got all these blank pieces of paper
and sitting in between so this is really
easy to do this free recall stuff and it
really helps you solidify your knowledge
for more specific topics there's more
specific strategies so flashcards are
good thing to do if you have to learn
paired associations so like an English
word and a Spanish word or like some
medical term and what it means or or
things like that you can do really well
with flashcards so there's lots of
different strategies I think the thing I
want to leave your listeners with right
now is just the idea that if you want to
be able to perform in a particular
situation you have to actually practice
retrieving not just reviewing yes
absolutely again to sing the songs have
Peter C Brown to make it stick episode
it'll be in the show notes below if you
if you feel like you have a particular
difficulty with retrieval Peters
approach for that and spaced repetition
were big fans of Anki on here and others
similar spaced repetition flashcard
programs one of the co-hosts is a doctor
who's just complete his medical degree
so he's like he's snowy he's got hankie
just coming out of his like eyebrows got
ankidroid so yeah we've gone we've gone
through retrieval what some of the other
principles of Ultra learning that you
think people should be aware of well so
there's one that I cover in the book
which I call intuition which is really
the idea that you're talking about when
you were talking about this in evolved
podcast which is that people don't need
to just have memorized facts these days
because if you are like what's the
capital of Hungary I can go up look that
up and what a pest comes up right so
there is a sense in which a lot of the
brute memorization of factual details is
a little overrated
nowadays I'm not gonna go so far as to
say that memorization or remembering
things is all as bad and this is why is
that when I was doing the research on
intuition one of the things that was
kind of surprising to me is that the
question of what does it mean to
understand something is actually a lot
more complicated than it first appears
there is a really interesting experiment
which is called the illusion of
explanatory depth I have it in the book
but basically the idea is do you know
how a bicycle works and most people
would say oh yeah I know how a bicycle
works and then I said can you draw one
and the funny thing is they've done this
is a study and they show people trying
to draw a bicycle and I don't mean like
some you know photorealistic rendering
I'm just talking about like do you know
where the chains connect and like what
are the pedals go and stuff and you see
some of these drawings and it's like
completely non-functional bicycles with
the chain and like the pedals are over
here and like it's rigid there's no like
handles so it's in the book you can look
at some of the the diagrams that are
that are from that actual study in there
but the thing is really important is
that why do people get that wrong why do
people think oh I could draw a bicycle
and then they can and the reason why is
that when we're talking about factual
knowledge again this is this judgment of
learning it's really easy to self assess
yourself so you can say what's the
capital of friends and if Paris doesn't
immediately come into your mind or
something else comes in your mind well
it's not London right then you just
don't know it and you can say no I don't
know whereas if I say do you understand
how a bicycle works there there's a lot
of nuance to that like you could
understand how to ride a bicycle you
could understand that bicycles are
things people ride on streets but maybe
you couldn't draw a bicycle maybe you
couldn't repair a bicycle maybe you
couldn't you know explain how the gear
mechanism works on a bicycle so the idea
here is that understandings are quite a
slippery concept and when I was doing
this research and looking in particular
this story for that chapter was for
Richard Fineman is that a lot of what
his sort of magical intuition is is
really actually a lot of stored patterns
in math and physics not just memorize
things but things that he was actively
using and working with all the time and
so his ability to just have a dis in
it seems to come from nowhere is really
built off this really large foundation
of tons of patterns and so why I'm a
little bit skeptical of the kind of
novel like we don't need to memorize
things advice is that true understanding
often comes from a place of having a lot
of things remembered now not necessarily
rote memorize the way that we do it in
school but if you don't have things
remembered if you don't have things that
you can recall for instance if you don't
have that knowledge in your head if it's
just out on Google then you won't have
that intuition and so there's a lot of
ideas that this one of the scientific
ideas is called chunking which is
basically saying that this kind of
stored patterns is a big part of the
reason why you see expert performers or
people who can do you seemingly
miraculous mental feats it's because
they have all these patterns so that the
classic studies were done on chess
grandmasters but you know it really
applies to lots of different subjects
couldn't agree more about the comment on
Navarre he is he says it in the podcast
with with Joe yeah he went to the
library in New York as he was growing up
as a child every night because his
mother wanted him to be safe before she
came home from working on an evening
time and he says himself he's like I
read everything there was in the library
from every magazine every textbook every
reference book anything I get my hands
on and you've struck on something that's
very interesting there that there is a
foundation of knowledge that navall is
standing on which is so much higher than
everybody else's he's able to connect
these concepts together because the base
knowledge that he has all of these
different nebulous like out on a limb
Baban spoke style concepts that he's got
going on he's got massive array at his
disposal that he can choose to use in
like that but if someone doesn't have
the foundation that they can build off
they don't have any mental models that
they can use for these these sort of
situations
you're gonna start bouncing off a
particular ceiling right so the thing I
would add to that in that discussion is
just that the way I see sort of the
comment what I would kind of amend if I
can you know and then someone else's
words what I would say that I would
think differently is that I agree it's
not so
that memorizing is not important but
that how you memorize or how you learn
things is what's important and the way
that we often do that to pass exams in
school is just not related to how you
actually apply it so this again goes to
the recall it goes to the directness
idea because it's not enough to have the
knowledge in your head it's not enough
to have it on some list somewhere that
you only used for one exam 20 years ago
but you have to have it in the context
where it applies so I have this at this
story that I've been telling which I
just it's really trivial but I just
think it's so good for illustrating that
I run a little business and we we sell
products and we were supposed to be
charging sales tax on top so if it's a
dollar it was opposed to be like 14
cents more but we weren't doing that or
software didn't do that so at the end of
the year we had to calculate the amount
of sales tax we should have paid them
but we didn't you know this kind of
thing and so one of my associates he was
like working on it he was like oh well
you know if the sales tax is 14% and it
was like $100 then it's just $14 and I
was like no it actually isn't that
because you know you have to think that
it's whatever the purchase price was
plus 14% has to equal $1 so you got to
get your algebra out and be like 1 plus
X and this and do the division and this
kind of thing and the funny thing was is
that like as soon as you frame the
problem it's like 1 plus X and the
dollar bro oh he knows how to solve it
immediately right this is like grade 8
math the problem is that in this
situation he didn't recognize that
that's what you have to do then that's
actually what the problem is asking you
and even if you'd heard a word problem
in a math class where they were asking
this he might have gotten the answer
correct it's just an issue of the
knowledge is there but it wasn't
accessible in that particular moment so
I think that a lot of what we're doing
with learning is not even so much
getting the knowledge inside of your
head or the skills inside your head but
creating the Association so that when
you were in the right situation it
arises as opposed to being sterile on
some memorize list somewhere
moving forward through a life of
prolonged learning as well I'm going to
guess that that will compound I mean the
must be some people that you spoke to
for the book who like Fineman I recently
had Mario Livio on talking about his new
book curious and in that he'd like
fineman's his
he's got a bit of a problem yeah he got
bit of a bromance going on with fighting
me too everyone does yeah exactly
so how how do you explain or did you
come across in fact any people who
seemingly had this kind of polymath like
unbelievable capacity any people that
are still around now that were that
would oh well there's there's tons of
people there's tons of people there just
like extraordinarily brilliant and just
have lots of different knowledge and
talks and a lot of these people aren't
even that famous I mean I just off the
top of my head right now a person who's
Bobby follow Marshall Revolution Tyler
Cao and who I even mentioned a little
bit in the book is just someone who like
always impresses me with just like the
sheer breadth of ideas that he covers
and there are people like phiman who are
kind of more specialized hauling ass
that they have like you know real deep
understanding of let's say physics and
that allows them to do incredible things
within physics you have people like
Terence Tao in the beginning of the book
who's just phenomenally brilliant with
mathematics and I think when you deal
with people who just know so much over a
long period of time it's really
difficult to kind of tease apart methods
or what are the different contributions
for their success largely just because
you know if they did have a natural
talent that compounding interest has
just been accelerating for so many years
that it's really hard to see well how
much was it that they did the right
things and how much of it was that
they're just really smarter or what what
have you but I do think that for the
average person listening here if you
start investing in learning skills now
and you start investing in just always
having a learning project doesn't have
to be full-time it just can be something
ongoing in your life you're always
learning new things you're always
picking up new stuff you'd be surprised
how fast it accumulates you know if you
just get the habit of you know reading a
book a month you're already starting to
compound and get it generate new ideas
so the the real shame is I think the
people who you know say to themselves
well I'm never gonna learn that so I'm
never gonna start and then they go 10 20
years they're outside of school they're
only doing the same thing every time and
their knowledge and skills just starts
to contract and then they're not able to
do that whereas if you keep staying
fresh you keep staying in the kind of
learning mindset yeah by the time you
were in your you know later years you
can have accumulated
quite a bit of knowledge and you'll be
like a smaller version of Eric Weinstein
who is as far as I'm concerned
essentially a different species to most
of us that guy that guys Bret and
understanding of across multiple fields
is insane I heard him talk with the same
degree of like resolution about maths
physics jazz music and cephalopods in
the space of like 10 minutes on a
podcast the end day but yes sort of to
round off the discussion that we've had
today I think that's a really nice point
to make Scott that what you're talking
about is the fact that there is a there
is a degradation over time of some of
the learning skills that you've used and
the longer that you kind of wait on that
the more difficult it's going to get but
the converse has to be true as well that
once you've done right I'm going to
Spain in two months time let's spend
four hours a week you know an hour a
night four nights a week I'm gonna
commit I'm going to make sure that my
learning process has been well planned
that its direct I'm going to drill down
into my specific skills I'm also then
going to do practice which is as close
to the situation as I can get I'll make
sure I'm working on my retrieval I'm
using my intuition and blah blah blah
all these sort of things once you've
done that first one the dominoes kind of
I'm gonna guess will continue to tumble
I also imagine as well this is speaking
as someone who hasn't done it but I have
to say has been quite romanticized by
the concept of doing an ultra learning
project I imagine that it must become an
addiction for some of the people that
you've spent your time with that they do
one and then you find oh hang on a
second he did a problems making project
now he's decided that he's going to
become a photographer oh my god he's
picked up the cell phone like well you
know it's funny I this is has sort of
been kind of my inspiration for writing
this book is that it's really hard to
communicate some experiences and so I'm
gonna try to do my best but one of the
reasons I was motivated to write this
it's not just you know obviously I think
learning is important and I think that
you know people will benefit from this
book even if they want to do something
small in their life or they want to just
a little bit better skills for their
work or their hobby or for their life
but I do feel like if you can go through
this process if you can do some sort of
project and set this challenge and do
something that felt impossible for you
and make it happen and have that
achievement in your life the feeling
that I had after doing the MIT challenge
wasn't just oh I've learned a lot of
computer science and no studying is hard
it was this feeling of well if you could
if I could do this what else could I do
and that's big reason I took on a lot of
these other projects is that it's you're
absolutely right it really does become
addictive and not just in the intense
can devote a lot of time to this but
there is a real kind of steamrolling of
self efficacy of feeling like you know
what actually I figured this out so I
could do something else and so I like to
think of it that you know these people
who you hear about let's say like Elon
Musk or Arnold Schwarzenegger who just
have like massive accomplishments in
many fields a lot of people see these
folks and that they say themselves well
this person must just be brilliant and
super and talented and you know what
they probably are but the other way I
see it is that this is someone who's
been on like a non-stop confidence like
positive feedback loop for like the last
thirty years that they've just been
accumulating more and more experiences
and so I'm hoping that for some people
who want to tackle an ambitious project
or they want to learn something hard or
they want to try to get good at
something that they care about they can
use this book and start that cycle going
and get that confidence so that they can
learn all sorts of other things in their
life that's awesome Scott I hope that
we've inspired some people to begin an
ultra learning project if helped you if
you are deciding to undertake one I
would love to hear from you and I'll be
able to pass it on to Scott so as always
drop me a message or tweet me actress
will X on all social media or make sure
that a link to ultra learning will be in
the show notes below don't forget that
if you follow the show link down there
you will be supporting the podcast by
buying the book through that at no extra
cost to yourself
Scott where can the listeners find you
online so obviously I would like it if
they can read the book if they want to
check out my website they can go to
scott h young calm and i have
been raiding for over a decade so
there's lots of articles about learning
habits goal-setting and self-improvement
amazing I will also make sure that I
linked to Scott's Twitter and if you've
got any questions you want to get to in
direct and feel free to hassle him on
there of course but yeah if if you're
gonna want to take one I'd love to hear
if this has inspired you to maybe
restart or continue your learning or add
an extra skill in my one for this summer
is to try and slackline so I'm gonna try
and get good at slacklining
the I'm definitely starting at the if I
can become even remotely competent at it
it will be a universe away from where
I'm at now but see well best of luck to
you I hope that the ideas of ultra
learning will help you there yeah me too
I'm worried I might not be salvageable
on that thing but we'll see I'll be
giving it I'll be giving it a crack
Scott thank you so much for your time
man yeah thanks for thanks for having me
it's been great chatting about this
stuff
[Music]